you have to keep in mind that
this is not the first time we are
discussing about nato
and not the first time we will discuss
about nato with russia
they have made it very clear earlier
years
that if you join nato they will do
whatever
they have explained
some contra steps
what they are
that is uh us for us to guess
but
now i got to get a bit deeper
the situation changed
so far even russia has said
that
having militarily non-aligned
finland and sweden
that will stabilize politics
that's what they have been talking
but
then in the end of last year
they stated that
finland and sweden
can't join
nato
they demanded that nato doesn't take new
members
actually they changed
their own picture by that
because
we have with sweden being non-aligned
militarily
from our own will
but
by stating that
russia actually expressed that
you don't have your own will here
and that is a huge change
that made us think
and what happened
in the 24th
february which continues
the huge warfare russia is
having in ukraine
surely that changed also the picture
they are
ready
to attack
the neighboring country
if that would be the case that we join
well my response would be that
you caused this
look at the mirror